Advanced Data protection Advanced Data
protection Advanced Data protection
Advanced Data protection is our most
advanced form of protection for
customers personal data in iCloud there
he is Apple's lead data security guard
okay fine senior vice president of
software engineering and he's announcing
the company's new yes an advanced data
protection or what most techie people
know as end-to-end encryption a security
feature to keep our data more secure
Apple will soon offer end-to-end
encryption to most of iCloud including
backups of your device and messages
photos notes and more
it's a big step which privacy groups
have called on the company to make for
years
what took so long some of the steps we
took over a decade ago in designing
iCloud and the way we encrypted were
necessary precursors to build uh toward
this moment and using ended encryption
for the other types of data like
passwords and browser history and so
forth help prove out that technology
what technology is that exactly I asked
federigi to break down all of this and
the bigger implications of security
tools like this can we take a picture
here a little selfie
allow me to explain end-to-end
encryption with a photo can I get like a
bunny fingers sure
I can't see where my fingers are but
okay now this photo lives in my iCloud
photos account with Apple's standard
data protection which is what we all
have now the photo is encrypted by the
device with a key that can unencrypt or
unlock the photo all that is encrypted
while it goes to Apple's server and
apple holds a key that can recover the
photo
hackers got access to Apple servers and
that key they could see the photo but if
I had Apple's Advanced Data protection
turned on that selfie would be
end-to-end encrypted meaning Apple
doesn't have the key at all and can't
see or unlock that photo well now with
Advanced Data protection we're giving
users the option to keep that key only
on their devices which means that even
if an attacker were to successfully
breach the cloud and access all that
data they'd lack the key to decrypt it
so you'll never see that photo Craig we
do not want to see your photo which gets
to one of the biggest issues Apple's had
with end-to-end encryption data recovery
if you can't get into your device you
wouldn't be able to access your data
because you're the only one with the key
now Apple doesn't have it but there are
incidences and you know we do see it
happen where customers not only lose
their device they also forget their
device passcode oh yes it's like you've
met my mother-in-law
well I think we we all have those yeah
and so in that case uh if your
mother-in-law had set up you say as her
recovery contact you would actually be
able with information you couldn't use
directly but that you could use to
assist her you'd be able to help her
recover her data that was protected with
Advanced Data protection Apple requires
you set up a back covering method and
thinking to recover end-to-end encrypted
data one option a recovery contact where
you can set up a friend or family member
to assist you with recovering info
there's also a recovery key option so
you can generate a key that you can
print out and keep in a secure location
well Apple already had end-to-end
encryption on services like health and
iCloud keychain the company's now
bringing it to a total of 23 services
but you will have to turn it on yourself
why not make this something that's
turned on by default a user activating
this feature is taking on an additional
responsibility they're taking on
responsibility for their data recovery
for setting up a recovery contact or
securing a recovery key all users may
not be ready or or willing to do that
with this sort of encryption enabled
companies even under court order cannot
hand over user data because they
technically can't even get it themselves
end-to-end encryption has long been
great for user privacy but awful for law
enforcement and governments who are
trying to get their hands on data to
help in investigate crimes is this
something that weighed into Apple's
decision as you roll this out we deeply
appreciate the work of law enforcement
and support the work of law enforcement
we view that we're really have the same
Mission at heart which is to keep people
safe ultimately keeping customers data
safe has big implications on our safety
more broadly there's sensitive
information that were an ill-intentioned
attack attacker whether that be a
foreign adversary or organized crime to
get access to information of our
political leaders or others who have
particular Secrets or access to to
systems could be disastrous for us all
and so we see this as important to
accomplishing the mission we share which
is to keep users safe and to end
encrypted iCloud backups will come to us
users before the end of the year and be
released globally in 2023. does that
include China oh yeah we believe so we
want to roll out across the the world do
you know how the Chinese government
feels about this they have not told me
in 2020 Reuters reported that Apple
dropped plans to let iPhone users fully
encrypt their backups after the FBI
complained that the move would harm
investigations
was this at all part of Apple's delay no
I I'm you know I've heard that rumor but
I I don't know where it came from in
addition to all of this Apple's also
introduced a new message contact key
verification which further verifies the
sender and receiver for those who
require extreme security you can also
now use a Hardware security key made by
other companies such as ubico to
authenticate your Apple account what's
the prompt for all these new security
features how much of it is aimed at
Pegasus and other recent attacks as
customers have put more and more of
their personal information of their of
their lives into their devices these
have become more and more the subject of
attacks by Advanced actors the only way
to ultimately secure against these
things is to stay one step ahead of the
attackers The Next Step does lies with
us and whether we decide to turn on
Advanced Data protection